our full case breakdown and dashboards
will be updated online tomorrow as usual
there are more signs over the past week
that we're putting the ba2 wave behind
us
our average pcr test positivity rate is
about twenty percent as compared to
twenty three percent last week and
twenty five point nine percent the week
before
this is the third week in a row that
we've seen dropping positivity rates
which means there is less vital viral
transmission in alberta
our wastewater surveillance program is
showing the same thing
the levels in most centers are declining
or fluctuating at levels well below the
ba1 peak
a number of sites are at quite low
levels like airdrie brooks drumheller
edson and grand prairie
wastewater data can fluctuate quite
wildly from day to day
due to factors in the virus as well as
the wastewater stream at a given site
some centers are showing a wide range of
variation but are continuing to trend
down like lethbridge
ebon calgary and red deer are well all
well past their recent peaks but still
showing significant amounts of virus
circulating it makes sense that levels
in larger centers are taking longer to
drop with their higher population
density
but we should get some help from better
weather so i hate i hope to see a broad
trend down
downward continuing on especially as we
get into warmer months
i'm also pleased to report that the
total number of admitted patients in our
hospitals with covid dropped slightly
again over the past week and the number
of ice in icu was flat as it has been
for several weeks
we recently increased the number of
permanent icu beds from 173 to 192 and
the total number of patients has well
been well within that number over the
past few weeks in fact it's been under
160 for the past few days
ahs has filled 250 positions to staff
those first 19 new icu beds this is out
of the 50 that we funded in budget 2022
that's a real step forward for our
entire health care system as a whole
the health care workforce is under
pressure in alberta and across the
entire country but we're building up
that workforce even as the pandemic
continues to cause strain in some areas
overall the data shows we're getting
past the ba2 wave and that's good news
it's a relief for all of us and
particularly for people who work in our
hospitals
it means fewer emissions fewer blocked
beds and fewer staff off sick
but pressure on this system still is
high with the major hospitals in
edmonton and calgary well over 90
occupancy and a few over 100 percent
emergency departments and ems are under
strain in particular due to high call
volumes and delays and offloading delays
that happen because some of the
hospitals are full particularly in their
emergency departments and emerge just
can't take the next patient as quickly
as they would they would wish to
there are a number
there are a number of reasons for the
surge in patients
we've been in a global health crisis for
two years and every province is facing
the same kinds of pressures for the same
range of reasons
but regardless it's clear that more than
ever we need to add capacity to our
entire health care system including our
ems system
budget 22
included 64 million dollars in new
funding to put more ambulance on the
streets and add air ambulance capacity
as well
i also appointed a committee to re to
assess ems
processes and the resources that we have
that we have in the system and i am
looking forward to their the interim
report from this alberta ems provincial
advisory committee which should be ready
by the end of the month
we'll look at more actions we can take
right away based on their
recommendations and also work towards
longer term solutions later this year
in the meantime the pressure on the
system is a reminder that we need to
keep looking for ways to protect people
and keep serious cases of coven 19 out
of our hospitals
now we recently expanded access to the
anti-viral drug pacslovid however it's a
treatment that must be taken early on in
a coven-19 infection and may have side
effects of its own
but it's effective at keeping at-risk
albertans with covenant 19 from
developing more serious illnesses
and of course vaccination remains the
best and easiest way to avoid severe
illness and outcomes
as i and dr hinchov said many times
getting your booster door your booster
doses
is important to ensure a high level of
protection against severe outcomes that
is why we encourage all albertans to get
every dose that you're eligible for
so please call today to make an
appointment or visit one of the clinics
that take walk-ins and with that thank
you and i now invite dr hinshaw to give
her update
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
turning to today's update
between tuesday may 10th and monday may
16th our pcr test positivity rate ranged
from 17.5 to 22.5 percent with an
average of 19.9 percent for the week
as the minister mentioned the average
number of people in hospital with covet
19 has decreased from last week
over the past week there has been a
daily average of around 1 190 people
with covet 19 in hospital
including around one around 39 in the
icu
sadly between may 10th and may 15th that
is last tuesday to this sunday
55 deaths related to covet 19 were
reported to alberta health which is an
average of approximately nine per day
tomorrow we will be reporting deaths
over the previous week in total
it is important to remember that each of
these numbers represents the loss of a
person who leaves behind grieving family
and friends
my sympathies are with the loved ones of
these albertans and with anyone who has
recently lost someone they cared about
no matter the cause
it's hard to see numbers such as these
due to a virus that has upended all of
our lives and is still prevalent despite
our collective efforts to put it in the
past
these are the most severe outcomes of
infection and the last impacts to fall
as a wave recedes
what we've seen in previous waves is
that leading indicators such as the
number of new cases
and lab positivity are typically the
first numbers to fall when the virus is
on the wane
changes in these early indicators are
then followed by lagging indicators such
as hospitalization numbers
deaths are usually one of the last
indicators to fall
this is why these high numbers of deaths
that we have seen in the past weeks as
well as this week
is not unexpected although it is a
tragic reminder of the severe impacts of
this virus
this is a late indicator showing the
impact of the ba2 surge
as we're seeing positivity and
hospitalizations begin to decline
consistently
we should expect to see the same thing
in the number of deaths very soon
having said that and as the minister
just referenced we must remember that
kovid will remain with us
we should expect it to return especially
when we get to colder months in the fall
and the start of the season when we
traditionally see a rise in respiratory
viruses
viruses like covid19 and influenza do
still pose a serious risk to many people
which is why it's important to stay up
to date on vaccinations and get all
doses that you're eligible for
it's important to have as many layers of
protection as possible to guard against
severe outcomes not only for ourselves
but for those who are most vulnerable
among us
we must also be honest with ourselves
and consider our own vulnerabilities not
just our physical health but our mental
health as well
these past few years have been very hard
on everyone
just like covid19 mental health issues
do not discriminate based on age or
circumstance
many albertans work tirelessly and
valiantly to maintain a sense of normal
during what was a very abnormal time
but the last two years have taken a
heavy toll
while many people have made it through
the height of the pandemic physically it
is important to acknowledge the impact
we have experienced to our mental health
i encourage you to make time to
prioritize your own mental health
if you need someone to talk to please
call two one one
someone will always be on the other end
of the line
24 hours a day 7 days a week
ahs also has a dedicated mental health
helpline you can call at
two 1-877-303-2600 four two
in addition to specialized supports
treatment and resources we can all take
steps to promote mental wellness
the coming summer season starting with
the may long weekend just around the
corner will provide opportunities to us
for rest
this could be camping a long walk
outside
a gathering with good friends or family
or even cheering on your favorite
alberta-based hockey team
the important thing is to make a plan to
do something that restores you
just as we have spent a lot of time
making sure we are physically healthy
it's time to safeguard and look after
our mental health as well
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr hinshaw no one here in the in
the room in edmonton but a couple on the
line so operator will go to the first
caller please
adam toy global
uh yes thanks for taking my questions uh
first one for dr hinshaw uh nasty still
hasn't updated guidelines on uh further
booster doses for the general population
but we've reached the five month mark
since the announcement for the third
dose is four people 18 plus uh were have
become available you mentioned last week
how important waiting that five month
period is um i'm wondering if you can
share any timeline for expansion uh
extended debate availability for fourth
does for albertans now that we've
reached that five-month mark since the
announcement um as well as since some
provinces like saskatchewan have also
expanded eligibility
we've been having a lot of conversations
with colleagues across the country and
with the alberta advisory committee on
immunization as well as the national
advisory committee it's important to
remember that vaccines like any other
intervention that we can offer either to
prevent or treat an illness
are
interventions that we have to think
about how to use most effectively and so
when we're looking at the national
advisory committee recommendations where
there was a strong recommendation to
offer that second booster to all those
age 80 and above there was a
discretionary recommendation about
potentially going down to age 70. that
was really based on the data that shows
the
impacts of the first
series of two plus the first booster so
three doses for most people
remains protective against severe
outcomes for the majority of people and
that that second booster dose is most
helpful in those who are at the oldest
age range or who have other risk factors
such as those who live in continuing
care
so we are continuing to look at the
evidence and
continuing to look at the national
advisory committee guidance
on what
groups will benefit most from that
additional dose
especially looking again at that risk of
severe outcomes it's important for
people to remember that those who are
younger
the the third dose is still very
effective at preventing severe outcomes
and
while we recognize that other provinces
have lowered the age we also know other
partner provinces like british columbia
are watching those national advisory
committee guidelines as we are so
i really we're focused on scientific
evidence and the populations that
benefit most which is where the advice
has come from both our alberta advisory
committee and the national advisory
committee
thanks dr henshaw adam follow up
uh yeah um you mentioned or i was
wondering if there's any uh serology
data astrology reports that you can uh
share with us in terms of uh prevalence
of of covet in the in the province um
and uh
like in in the past waves uh whether or
not um
you know and if we have in fact uh hit a
peak of the sixth wave uh wondering if
you can share any any insights from that
information
the last serology survey that was
completed was at the beginning of march
it typically takes us about six weeks to
get
the tests done the data analyzed and
then to be able to work on that data to
be able to
share that with the public and share the
the information about what the serology
data tells us about the ratios of
the pcr testing to perhaps what the
the under the water part of the iceberg
is with respect to the number of total
cases
in this particular instance it's taking
us longer than we anticipated to do that
full suite of analyses so i expect that
the serology data would be something we
would have ready to share
within the next several weeks but it is
just taking us a little bit longer than
we had expected so ultimately again we'd
expected to be able to share that at the
end of april um but we're wanting to
make sure that we're we're completing a
robust series of analysis that's
specific to the omicron wave
so you can look for that to be available
by the end of this month
thanks for that dr hinshaw we'll go to
the next caller please i think we'll
have time for two more so second last
one
jennifer lee cbc
hi there thanks for taking my question
uh this is for dr hinshaw
you talked about um alberta's covet
hospitalization numbers and the fact
they're a lagging indicator but you know
looking back after ba one and that wave
you know the drop in hospitalizations
while there wasn't as dramatic as the
drop we saw in previous waves
and i just wonder what you anticipate um
with hospitalizations in the months to
come as we come off if we are coming off
of ba2
um do you anticipate they'll still
remain
higher than what we've seen in the past
um
like what do you anticipate will happen
and can we expect a more dramatic drop
without
the kind of health measures we had in
place to limit spread after previous
waves
one of the interesting things about
comparing the the first omicron wave in
the second omicron wave is looking at
the icu numbers
so while the overall hospitalization
numbers
haven't declined as dramatically we did
see
more of a drop in the the icu numbers
one of the things that we've been
talking about with colleagues across the
country is how do we most accurately
give
the public a sense of what the covet
impact is on hospitals
because we know that there is a portion
of the hospitalization numbers that are
people who are admitted to hospitals for
other reasons so we do share that
information on our weekly updates the
percentage of those who are admitted
where covid is an incidental finding and
not related to their hospitalization um
so i think
what's important for the public to know
is that
again as we've said covid19 is with us
for the
foreseeable future that it's something
that will likely go up and down probably
in part influenced by seasonality
that we will
likely see similar to influenza a low
level of cases even throughout the
summer we would expect that we would see
more cases in the fall and winter in our
respiratory season um but that we're
still in that transition period where
we haven't quite reached what what we
would expect the um
the uh kind of normalized state to be so
i would expect in the next several
months we will see a decline in
hospitalizations
with covid
but they will remain at a at a lower
level i don't expect they would get down
to zero anytime soon
and that we would see a surge again
certainly in the fall is is most likely
thanks dr henshaw jenna follow up
yeah i do thanks i'm wondering dr
hinchoff you can provide an update on
the situation
with severe acute hepatitis cases in
children
have any further possible cases be been
identified since you announced this to
last week
haven't you been confirmed
can you just give us an update on sort
of where those investigations are at
sure we've been working with clinical
colleagues and also working with
partners at the national level and other
provinces and territories
the two cases that i spoke about last
week
after further conversation with the
public health agency of canada and with
local clinicians
do meet the probable case definition
which means that at this time there's no
clear
explainable cause of the hepatitis and
so
again those particular cases
the the clinical condition hasn't
changed at all
but the initial set of investigations
has ruled out the most common causes of
hepatitis we are working to make sure
that the
reporting process is clear so this is
obviously something that's still new
it's something that we're wanting to
make sure that our clinical colleagues
understand who to report to
so there may be additional cases as we
work to clarify those reporting
connections but at this time we have the
two probable cases in alberta
thanks for talking shaw we'll take one
more caller please
catherine krakowski alberta today
hi thanks for taking my question um so
if somebody has had uh one or two shots
of astrazeneca and then their third dose
of mrna is that they're those still
considered
effective will they need to get boosters
we know that there are
many people in this circumstance who may
have received either a single dose or a
full series of astrazeneca and then may
have received one or two doses of an
mrna vaccine last summer so they would
be beyond that five months from their
third or fourth dose depending on again
whether they
they received a full astrazeneca series
and then a full mrna series
we have brought that specific question
to our alberta advisory committee to
assess the
need for offering additional doses to
those individuals since they have had
what would be considered to be a booster
dose in in those circumstances at this
time our advisory committee has
recommended that we consider
the final dose to be their booster dose
it is something that we continue to
discuss with them and look at emerging
evidence just with respect to um
considering how long the protection
against severe outcomes would last so if
anything changes on that front we will
of course let albertans know but at this
time we are following the
recommendations of our advisory
committee with respect to that specific
population
thanks dr hanchod catherine follow up
yeah on a
different topic he had mentioned
the importance of mental health and you
know doing all those activities we enjoy
the camping on a long weekend or
watching a hockey game
i'm wondering with hospitals in edmonton
and calgary
um some of them above 100
capacity
how concerned are you about um a surge
or the
ability to get care when
when known long weekends there tend to
be things like impaired driving or or
incidents that land people in hospital
what would be your advice for
staying out of hospital i guess
yeah it's a great point and we do often
see
long weekends especially
the beginning of our summer season as
times where injuries do
potentially go up i think one of the
most important things to remember is
that
it's never appropriate to mix alcohol or
cannabis with uh
other
activities like
driving or operating any kind of motor
vehicle
that's extremely dangerous and certainly
not just a potential cause for injury in
the person who's operating the vehicle
but
the people who may be around them either
passengers or in other vehicles so i
would say that anyone who's making plans
to
be outdoors especially if it involves
[Music]
using you know either driving or using a
recreational vehicle of some kind
to make plans to ensure that the driver
is somebody who's not using those
substances it's also important to take
basic safety precautions having a backup
plan making sure that
any of the activities that people are
participating in they're comfortable
with familiar with have the safety gear
and
you know are able to
to get supports if so for example not um
going hiking in unfamiliar areas if uh
if you don't have a safety plan or a
backup plan so just really using the the
basic safety precautions making sure
that any kind of impairing substances
aren't used with motor vehicles
making sure that
kids for example are well supervised we
know that
younger kids can
unfortunately be injured if they're
doing activities
and not supervised so those are all the
kinds of things that we would always
recommend but particularly on a long
weekend making sure that as we all get
back outside and back into activities
that we enjoy that we're doing so
safely thanks for that dr hinshaw we'll
wrap up there i'll see you again next
week and since they're the very last
words of the day go oilers